In the old world of
the personal computer,
most applications came
in the form of a disc.
To run an application,
you would install it
onto your computer, where
there you could execute it,
creating and saving files as
needed to your hard drive.
The problem with
this is obvious.
You may have multiple
computers you
want to access
your project from.
It's stuck on one, and if
that computer isn't backed up,
you could easily end up losing
your progress due to computer
failure.
Luckily, with the
growth of the internet,
most of these
applications, which
were traditionally offline,
have been moving online
as web applications.
With this improvement,
we can easily
access these apps
from any computer
and not have to worry about
keeping our data in sync.
However, with this
evolution, we've
shifted a lot of responsibility
onto the developer
of these websites to
properly store user data,
keep backups, and
facilitate sharing properly.
As you can imagine,
this is no small task.
This is where Google
Drive comes in.
Google Drive can be thought of
as a user's personal hard drive
in the cloud.
What does that mean exactly?
Well, let me tell you.
Drive is built to be the
place where you store,
share, and collaborate
on personal files
across multiple desktops
or mobile devices.
And it's all stored on
Google's infrastructure,
ensuring your data is safe,
secure, and always backed up.
Here's where it starts
to get interesting.
See, Google recently
created a Drive API,
which allows developers to
easily store and retrieve data
from a customer's Google Drive,
their personal hard drive
in the cloud.
This data could be anything, a
document, image, video, song,
or even save game data
recording how far you
got in your latest dungeon raid.
All this data can be saved using
Google's infrastructure, which
will take care of backups,
scale with your application,
and make it super simple to
sync across multiple devices.
This way, developers
can focus more
on building great applications
and leave the cloud storage
to the experts by using
the Google Drive API.